what do you think of Megan McCain's
recent column criticizing The View and
saying that the show just keeps getting
worse
oh let me take a drink Sonny hoston
weighs in after her former view co-host
Megan McCain slams the daytime talk show
who doesn't want to talk about the view
who doesn't want to write about the view
it all went down during Thursday's
episode of Watch What Happens live with
Andy Cohen when a caller asked Sonny
about a recent call of Megan wrote
condemning The View claiming it was a
toxic work environment I have not read
the column okay I did I have heard about
it our show is a wonderful place and
ratings are great they've always been
great and they're really good now we're
the number one talk show in the country
I'm just thrilled that we are doing
better in the ratings than we've done in
a really long time of course Megan
joined the show in October 2017 after
leaving Fox News and was an outspoken
conservative voice on a primarily
liberal panel until she left in 2021. I
try and just remind myself that I'm
representing 50 of the country we are
friends and I think when you see five
women
that are passionate that are discussing
really deep topics the headlines are
always this one hates that one and caddy
and this and that no we are five smart
women that care about what's happening
in our country that's what the view is
about over the years Megan found herself
in heated arguments with several of her
co-hosts including Whoopi Goldberg and
Joy Behar I think that's why people like
the show is they know it's not scripted
and they know it's not we're not being
phony and I'm not trying to placate to
an audience but despite any on-air
disputes Megan and joy told E.T their
relationship behind the scenes was
nothing but love what is the one thing
you want the public to know about our
relationship that we like each other
they keep writing things about how we
can't stand each other it really hurts
my feelings and I wish people would give
us a break but in her column Megan tells
a different story calling out joy and
whoopee alleging they avoided discussing
major news topics on the show what we're
saying we really mean it it's not an act
we don't sugar coat it we go right and
that's what we have in common and I
think that there's mutual respect for
that she also compared her exit from the
view to having a very public very nasty
breakup with an Infamous ex-boyfriend
last year Megan said Sunny was the only
co-host on The View she still keeps in
touch with I have like such love for her
and I respect her and yeah she's a
really good person and she didn't
demonize me the way a lot of other
people did whatever that's worth Meg and
I've always been friendly right we
remain friends and I don't think she's
doing television anymore I think you
should hire her for one of the
housewives franchise and she'd be a
great she'd be great on on Potomac or
any of them Megan McCain joining The
Real Housewives Bravo fans don't hold
your breath do you tune in from time to
time since you've Departed the show
never E.T was with Megan at the time 100
Gala in New York City this week where
she admitted that not only does she not
watch The View she doesn't have cable at
all I'm a cord cutter now so I don't my
husband we like moved and then we were
like should we install cable and I was
like let's just not and it's actually
like lovely to choose Your Entertainment
well Megan may not be on our TV anymore
but she still knows how to keep us
talking
foreign